To diagnose tuberculosis, doctors must analyze an average of 100 images.
It's a long process that requires identifying and counting the bacteria,...
...which cause the disease.
The researchers behind a new program called TuberSpot want to make the practice more attractive.
That's why they've created a video game platform to diagnose the disease.
Players can help analyze actual images of patient samples,...
...and they don't have to be experts in medicine.
The game requires them to seek and hunt bacteria before they run out of time.
Tuberculosis affects the lungs and the disease spreads through the air.
According to the World Health Organization, ten million people develop TB every year.
It killed more than one million humans in 2013.
Spanish researchers created TuberSpot for International Tuberculosis Day,...
...which takes place on March 24th.
The application is now available on Google Play...
...and can be played on desktop web browsers too.